ambiente de un drama seguro para al
menos uno de los dos equipos En el
terreno de juego finalmente ese drama
esas lágrimas son para Inglaterra que
cae eliminada en estos cuartos de final
contra Francia los campeones del mundo
que avanzan de nuevo a semifinales y se
medirán contra Marruecos buscando
defender su corona un partido en el que
de nuevo Vimos a una Inglaterra que al
igual que ocurrió contra senegal en
octavos de final salió muy desconectada
del partido algo que aprovechó Francia
para adelantarse por mediación de y uno
de los debutantes en esta copa mundo los
ingleses que al igual que contra senegal
fueron poco a poco entrando en el
partido fue así como lograron la
igualdad allá en los segundos 45 minutos
por mediación de Harry kane un penalti
que lo convertía en el máximo goleador
para los tres leones igualando a Wayne
rooney el partido que justo cuando
Inglaterra estaba demostrando su mejor
fútbol cuando bocallo saca estaba
encontrando las cosquillas de Teo
Hernández Cuando Harry kane estaba
participando más fue ahí como apareció
el otro 9 esta vez el 9 de Francia Olive
action quien anotó también su gol número
53 para seguir
mostrándose como el goleador histórico
de la selección francesa y para
redondear este partido con una montaña
rusa de emociones llegó de nuevo un
penalti para Harry kane que esta vez no
pudo convertir lo falló el delantero del
tottenham lo falló el máximo goleador
para los británicos los penaltis así
como fueron una tristeza para los
británicos en
1990 en 1996 y también en 1998 en una
Eurocopa hay dos mundiales y así como
sonrieron a los británicos en Rusia 2018
esta vez vuelven a ver la cara oscura de
la moneda le salió cruz en la tanda en
los penaltis a los británicos con ese
tiro de Harry kane que seguramente no
olvidará
pues Juan veíamos ahora en directo
también unas imágenes del arco del
triunfo en Francia que seguro Dentro de
pocos minutos estará lleno de gente
celebrando este nuevo pase a semifinales
y desde luego no será un momento bonito
para Harry que muchas gracias por este
reporte